this is gemma  nearly eight feet tall she is one big  bacterian camel the largest of all  living camel species  gemma is 15 years old which places her  at middle age for bactrian camels  native to the steps of central asia  bactrian camels have two humps not one  and contrary to what many people think  their humps contain fat not water  they convert the stored fat into energy  which can be used in place of water or  food  this along with their clumpy woolly  coats and tolerance for high altitudes  make them the perfect companions for  long difficult journeys  domesticated bacterian camels are  abundant but wild ones are critically  endangered due to hunting and loss of  habitat  over the course of the next couple of  generations their numbers outside of  domesticity are expected to dwindle to  just a quarter of its current population  this is the bacterian camel  [Music]  you